- [Voiceover] We wanna figure
out what AX plus B squared is,
and I encourage you to pause the video
and figure out what that is
in terms of capital-A and capital-B.
So let's work through it.
This is the same thing as multiplying
AX plus B times AX plus B.
So let me fill that in.
This is AX there, another AX there.
I just wrote it in that order
to make the color switching
a little bit easier.
So AX plus B times AX plus B.
Well, what's that going to be equal to?
Well, if you take this AX
and you multiply it times
that AX, you're going to get AX squared.
AX, the entire thing squared.
And then if you take, if you take this AX
and then multiply it times this B,
you're going to get ABX.
Then if you take this
B and you multiply it
times this AX, you're
going to get another ABX.
ABX.
And then last but not
least, if you take this B
and multiply it times the other B,
it's going to be plus B squared.
And so what are you left with?
Well, you're going to be left with A,
I'll write it like this,
AX squared, we actually if we want,
well, I'll write it in a
different way in a second,
and then you have plus, plus two,
that's a slightly different color.
I'm gonna do that other color.
Plus two ABX,
and then finally plus B squared.
Plus B squared.
Now, I said I could write it
in a slightly different way,
what I could do is just
rewrite-out AX squared
as being the same thing.
This is the same thing
as A-squared X-squared,
and then I can write out
everything else the same way.
Plus two ABX,
and then plus B squared.
Now, why did I, what's
interesting about doing this?
Well, now we can see the pattern
for the square of any binomial
or binomial like this,
so for example, if someone
were to walk up to you
and say "alright, I have
a trinomial of the form,"
let's say they have a
trinomial of the form
25X squared
plus 20X plus 4,
and they were to tell you to factor this,
well, actually, let's just do that.
Why don't you pause the video and see
if you could factor this as
the product of two binomials.
Well, when you look at this,
you'd say "well look, there's 25X squared,
"that looks like a perfect square.
"25X squared, that's the
same thing as five-squared
"x-squared,"
or you could write it as five X squared.
This four here, that's a perfect square.
That's the same thing as two squared.
And let's see, 20, right over here,
if we want it to fit this pattern,
we would see that A is five and B is two,
and so let's see, what
would be two times AB?
Well, five times two AB would be 10,
and then two times that would be 20.
So this right over here is,
that is plus two times five.
Two times five times two
times two X.
Times two X, I'll do it in this color.
Times two X.
So you see that this completely
matches this pattern here
where A is equal to five
and B is equal to two.
Once again, this is AX,
the whole thing squared,
then you have two times A times BX,
you see that there,
and then finally you have the B squared.
So if you wanted to
factor this, you could say
"well, this is just
going to the same thing
"since we know what A and B are,
"this is going to be five X plus two."
Five X plus two.
Five X plus two, whole thing squared.
So the whole point of doing
this is to start recognizing
when we actually have perfect squares,
especially perfect squares
where the leading coefficient
isn't one.